6 minutes to the easy I'm shooting we
got big problem this your first
mission
second here we go this is Reaper 10
checking in Reaper one0 this is Playboy
06 Roger Playboy I am your eyes in the
sky and the bringer of Doom
subtle gaset disappeared 2 weeks ago
believe to be kidnapped so this is a
rescue
off the hell are these guys we got a
situation reap your clear copied impact
seconds I see him scan forward keep me
with him
copy give me the status of your team
hey copy Playboy we got you he's
freaking out you got to calm him down
help helicopter is inbound to the Evac
point you got to get your ass on the
move
Son you got to move man come on
Soldier we are taking heavy fire
blackberg can you stay in the area
taking in the
course get up and
go Playboy where are you can't talk
right
now
lost
comms we're going to drop bombs on these
caves we don't get out of here we're all
going to
die there's no way I'm off this
off drop that bomb
our priority is protecting the men and
women who serve this
country welcome to land
[Music]
B